ladies and gentlemen i'm just going to
cut it straight with you i have no idea
why anyone watches this channel
no discernible life skills except for
just ranting in the 10 million
studio and by the way that's all that's
a house of cards that's folding down
real quick
okay rent's coming due and i am
underwater the bank account just
there's not even a balance it just says
overdrawn all the time
over here in debt wondering what to do
and suddenly
i had a moment an archimedes eureka
moment where i was sitting
right here just admiring my knowledge
and i said to myself stephen
you have no skills you pissed away your
degree quite frankly done nothing with
it you had that coffee break jenna you
don't do anything with that
what no life skills what can you do if
you have
no life skills to speak of and i've
realized
become a youtube wealth advisor
that's right guys this is my big
announcement i'm now a youtube wealth
advisor you can expect
exciting new videos like the top 10
altcoins or
five coins to five billion dollars or
you know
how to invest for dummies buy a dummy
that's what you can expect from this
channel now now why would i do that
but before i get into that let me first
say i've gotta shill the channel
pump the stock pumpzilla not the penny
stock or whatever that is pump zilla
the channel please it costs you nothing
for free
you can subscribe like but anyways why
am i qualified to be a wealth advisor
well
like i said i have no skills so that
already qualifies me to a certain extent
but i also have something none of these
other guys have
i was looking like what makes a youtube
wealth advisor popular what makes people
like them
and the answer is of course that they
have
a lot of knowledge i mean a lot of um
you know cars though but uh knowledge
in the sense of in the truer sense which
is what knowledge really is right we
don't actually think that knowledge is
about
knowing things it's actually about
having
nice cars that you can flex on other
people
so i was looking at ricky obviously a
top tier youtube wealth advisor
what does ricky have the blue the baby
blue lamborghini huracan
look that qualifies him
yeah qualification look there's that
you got oh graham stefan here what's up
you guys it's graham here
sick car graham okay you're qualified
meet kevin
qualified awesome hard top convertible
which yes
dad look at that who wait who's this
what the hell this guy these wheels yeah
well
okay you know wealth advisor what is
this what kind of car is this caddy i
think it's about five years or so
okay obviously this guy has no social
presence sorry about i don't know how he
snuck in there
uh look there we go a real wealth
advisor hey this is tim sykes
millionaire
millionaire trader and i am here going
to look for my new exotic car look
he's qualified clearly he's passed the
test
now why am i going to tell you today
that i'm the new number one wealth
advisor on youtube on this platform and
i want everyone to say
why let me show you it's very simple
they can go like this with their car
right that's pretty normal coffeezilla
wealth advisor
i mean need i say more though i mean
literally
your guru who's your favorite guru can
they do this
what's dave ramsey got on this what does
meat kevin have to answer to this
what's tom nash got you think he's got
one of these no
this is a one of one they made it just
for me and
uh i even took it a test drive around
town so if you want to go ahead
and subscribe to the new wealth advisor
channel go ahead do that right now thank
you guys for watching thank you for
supporting all my dreams
wouldn't have been possible without you
for me to become so incompetent but
simultaneously
so wealthy on this platform so it's all
thanks to you guys
you can get rich by subscribing to me
right now it's a verifiable
falsehood and uh thanks for watching
i'll see you guys next time